in other world news Honduras has
formally broken off decades-long
diplomatic relations with Taiwan and
switched to China it comes after the
Honduran foreign minister traveled to
Beijing to discuss establishing ties
this leaves Taiwan with only 13
diplomatic allies China considers South
Rural Taiwan as part of its territory to
be retaken by forces necessary the US
says honduras's action is a sovereign
decision but has warned that China often
makes empty promises
we will not engage in meaningless Dollar
Diplomacy with China in the past few
years China has constantly used various
methods to suppress taiwan's
International participation has
increased its military incursions
against us and attack Regional peace and
stability these pressures and threats
were not all to the reality that Taiwan
and the People's Republic of China are
not affiliated with each other neither
will they decrease the will of the
Taiwanese people to insist on freedom
and democracy while walking with big
strides towards the world
or let's speak to Vincent ciao about
this is a Taiwanese politician and a
former Diplomat he's joining us live
from Taipei thank you for your time
thank you for being on Al Jazeera so
Honduras is now the ninth diplomatic
Ally that Taiwan has lost to Beijing
since saying Wayne took office as
president she's pro-independence we know
what is your reaction first and how big
of a blow is this for Taiwan
well certainly it's uh the latest and a
long line of diplomatic switches we've
seen over the past few years China has
been very intent on
um taking away taiwan's International
Space through political means through
economic means and through Foreign
Affairs means and diplomatic means and
certainly I think Honduras is reflective
of that I mean it's it it was a bigger
blow I guess a few years ago when
taiwan's diplomatic allies started to
switch given that this is the latest and
a long line of them happening you know
domestically there isn't as big of a
political reaction as there once was I
think people have recognized that uh
China's intent on engaging in this
Dollar Diplomacy
um to try to switch taiwan's diplomatic
allies and the best thing we can do
about it in response is to strengthen
our Partnerships with non-diplomatic
allies including United States Japan and
other like-minded democracies around the
world I'll ask you a bit more about what
what taiwan's response could be in
trying to get some more allies on its
side but if China is isolating Taipei
right now what does it mean for taiwan's
independent Ambitions do you think it's
a big setback is it having an impact
well I think certainly
um the way this government sees um
taiwan's situation politically is that
we are a sovereign and petting country
called the Republic of China and there's
no subordination to the People's
Republic of China based in Beijing and
so the president made that clear in the
club you've shown a couple minutes ago
and so you know in the sense that yes it
is a blow to Town's International
recognition but no it is not a biggest
deal as it once was and you know I think
people are more intent and focused on
right now which is the security sphere
on on Regional Security on Cross trade
issues on ensuring a great relationship
with the Us and other security Partners
so that's sort of where the foreign and
diplomatic Affairs focus is right now
rather than maintaining a larger amount
of diplomatic allies right but the way
China has done this I mean China has
spent billions to to win recognitions
for its One China principle what is now
Taiwan prepared to do not to lose this
diplomatic battle and end up perhaps
being completely isolated
well the issue with China is that it's
very difficult to compete dollar to
dollar against him oh number one I mean
they've made a lot of lavish promises
that may or may not have come true in
the past but more problematically some
of these um Dollar Diplomacy have gone
to private pockets and so we saw this
recent exposure for example by
micronesia's president that the Chinese
Ambassador they're openly bribed for
example city government officials so
that's sort of what we're dealing
against and I'm not sure how do you
respond to that thing
how do you respond to that
well easily I think we're not just we're
just not going to play that game I think
we're going to keep things stable we're
going to do our best and to providing
substantive assistant that works but
we're not going to engage and we're not
going to try to outbid each other and
we're not going to try two possible
broad government officials for
diplomatic needs okay thank you so much
for talking to us thank you for your
time Vincent's ciao